INTERVIEWER: I'm on my way to
meet a man who has been chosen
to lead his people in an
epic struggle, one that also
requires super human endurance.
He's asked me to come to
Devils Tower in Wyoming.
This is Chief Arvol
Looking Horse,
the Chosen One of the Nakota,
Lakota, and Dakota tribes.
[music playing]
CHIEF ARVOL LOOKING HORSE:
[non-english speech]
INTERVIEWER: Aha.
I brought him a gift of tobacco
for his sacred ceremony.
CHIEF ARVOL LOOKING HORSE: Oho.
Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: So chief, tell
me, why did you want me to meet
you here at Devil's Tower?
CHIEF ARVOL LOOKING HORSE: We
call it [non-english speech].
INTERVIEWER:
[non-english speech]
CHIEF ARVOL LOOKING HORSE: Ah,
that's one of our power points
of prayer, of worship.
It's like a church.
This is where white
Buffalo Calf Woman brought
the sacred pipe to our people.
So the story is that
19 generations ago
our people were camped here.
At the time, there was no
more food because people
were abusing life.
From a distance
they saw a cloud.
And then, from that
cloud there's a woman.
She brought the sacred pipe.
She said, I'm bringing
this sacred bundle
to you that you shall
live in peace and harmony.
[non-english speech]
INTERVIEWER: The White Buffalo
Calf Woman taught Chief Arvol's
people how to
respect Mother Earth
and worship the Great Spirit
with the sacred pipe she
gave them.
Does it still exist?
CHIEF ARVOL LOOKING HORSE: Yes.
Since the age of
12 years old, I've
been the keeper of the sacred
White Buffalo Calf Bundle,
or pipe.
They call me
[non-english speech].
INTERVIEWER:
[non-english speech]
CHIEF ARVOL LOOKING HORSE:
Mm, [non-english speech]
INTERVIEWER: The White
Buffalo Calf pipe is so sacred
that Chief Arvol
cannot let anyone
outside of his tribes see it.
So your grandmother was
the keeper of the pipe.
CHIEF ARVOL LOOKING HORSE: Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: She said that
you were to be next in line?
CHIEF ARVOL LOOKING HORSE: Yes.
My grandmother, on her
deathbed, she told my family,
we are the crossroads.
Earth changes, climate changes.
And that if the people
don't straighten up,
then he shall be the
last bundle keeper.